[Music]
it's amazing how many people you get to
know over the years and this is kind of
like a family reunion where you get to
see everyone I didn't know that there
were so many enthusiastic JavaScript
developers in Hamburg and this group is
like so diverse I never imagined we had
such a passionate and terrific community
that was pretty eye-opening
[Music]
I like this conference a lot I was in
this conference last year and I came
this year again even it's a very good
conference that people are very friendly
it's also very interesting thanks to
everyone who participated in this
conference organizers making food
amazing
[Music]
I like this kind of style that everyone
seems to like I have a voice
[Music]
love the JSON con finding organizer and
former days
I love the new venue actually I want to
keep it I don't want to go back to the
old one I think it's something very
special in Hamburg
[Music]
I am actually not a JavaScript developer
but I go to a lot of JavaScript maybe
just to where the ones know see you next
year